来这个高货一款半身鞋
灰色
灰色的这一款
灰色高货
高货一个半身鞋
这个QU11的好像是
一万多的一个雕牌价
这和我自留的那个一样的
我留了一个黑色和灰色
这没有标了
我天哪
这上面没有标
原价59的这一条
半身鞋灰色长款
我留的就是这一款
这个长款的
来这个腰尾看一下
板相很好
A字板
腰尾62
6266的腰
62 66
平微不限
群长
群长是80
群长80
这个29给你们
29扣9扣9
29块扣个9
妹猪妈来了
早上好早上好
今天在家里
不用回公司了
要不然这么早没时间打招呼
来这个
这个29块
灰色灰色一个高货半圈
扣9扣9
29块
还有一个颜色呢
这个有两个颜色
最近业绩不咋样
应该不咋样
昨天我休息了
我女儿抱田志愿
田志愿去了
老四突然通知要去田志愿了
昨天去田志愿去了
休息了一天
这个牌子
这个牌这个牌
来标的是聚值56
人年24毛18
捐着2
这一条单圈
实单有没有实弹有实弹有
还好吧
前天前天前天十来单
然后再前一天好像
那天最多30多
然后昨天休息
然后再前天好像十单都没有
就这样子
上衣有不有上衣有
你说是哪个随便啥样的上衣
刚刚我过了一袋的上衣
上衣也有你炖一会
你女儿结果出来
生物物理和化学
真好
我身上的没有了
我身上的我自己的没有了
来这个高货半圈
腰围62 66的腰
62 66
也两个一样大
长度是80
我身上的没有了
亲爱的
我身上都两三年前的了
两年前的了
应该是来这个有要的扣
这个29扣一
29块扣一扣一
K1YY的这个是
来这个29块扣一扣一
1万多的高货半圈
面料是毛
是一面面剧者婚访的
这个是原价是59的
1万多的高货
现在都没几件了
骨品都给你们放29了
一个灰色
一个米性色的
这里还有一个裙子
这个牌子也好
这个牌开单了
没有
来这个
今天不知道怎么样了
这个裙子长得很
你没发标
我发啥标
啥发标了
是我前列发标了
我来这个腰围
腰围66-68
腿围108-20
裙长95来
裙长95
这个29扣5
高货高货
29块扣5扣5
啥发脾气
发标了
气坏了
冬天给我发信息
正好我在加油站加油了
我说谁打电话
一看又瞎打了
我怎么办
怎么办
一件还没卖
都快下班了
这怎么熬
你说说我们这怎么熬
来这一款身上是一个全棉
他打电话问刘老板
赶快拿新款来
熬不住了
来袖子的话是一个棉和锯子婚纺
身上是一个全棉的
来这一款胸围
胸围是106-106-134
106-134
长度73
来这个9块9块9块
扣3扣3
身上是一个黑色
袖子拼接一个白色
他是不是桃花眼了
最后拿几单裤子
啊
你别吓我
我现在想到裤子我都害怕
来这个9块9块9块扣8扣8
9块扣个8
全棉的身上是
然后袖子是拼接了一个
拼接了一个棉婚纺的
9块钱
这里还有一条粉色
看看高货区出来三条了
这个是长款的一个粉色
长款的一个粉色粉色
你觉得他在外面旅游
带老婆出去玩去了
呗
Q111的这一款是
锯纸锯鞍纸的
锯纸锯鞍纸这个牌子一万多的一个雕牌价
这个牌这个牌
就是到现在都出去这么久了
还不整一点来
来这个腰围看一下
腰围是66能拉伸78
6678的腰群长81群长81
这个29扣个1
这个原来都是59的
虚惊旺那边拿货也应该回来了
就是的
来这个2929扣1扣1这一款
这个板线很好
大板很大的一个
这个夏天可以穿
刚刚那两条春秋天穿可以
来这个29块
29块扣2扣2
29扣个2
我给他发群里来
这个是昨几天谁要的
这个夏天穿了一个圈
小黄油在不
是不是小黄油要的
忘了
昨几天谁要这个牌子了
我放到群里去
还得也拍一个
来来来
所以你订伍单是没错的
我就订伍单吧
别想这么多了
嗯
OK
我放这里
那去你买了
来来来
就那基本金薪资就行
不想多
我天天天天 Hide
时间好一点都行
来这个
这个上面刺绣字母加胶印字母的这款卫衣
后面连帽的这个是
这个属于一个浅绿色的
绿色绿色的这款
卫衣卫衣
来胸围
胸围120146
来这个衣长
衣长71的
衣长是71
发表
给刘老板打电话
来这个9块
9块扣个5
9块9块扣5扣5
我哪天
卖个两三件
不超过5件
我也得打电话
哎呦
得打电话问问
明天打
明天打打
明天打问问
你拿货拿多少了
赶快来
来这个
这个是
这个是一个小上衣
黄色
上面这里有刺绣的一个logo的
刺绣刺绣
然后这个后面
有一点蓝色的
粘了一点点蓝色的纱
来
来这一款胸围
胸围116124
来这个长度
长度67
这个9块
9块扣个8
9块9块扣8扣8这一块
9块钱扣个8扣个8
9块扣8
来这一个
这个是一个打底
灰色前围后围的这一块
胸围
胸围是106
130的胸围长度
长度60到70
这个9块
扣5
9块钱扣5扣5
单撰打底都可以
棉混纺
棉混纺的
9块钱扣5扣5
来这个
这个是马50 棉50的这一款
这个是来货49的
这个原来卖49的
里面一个小小袖子有个钮扣
然后袖子的
上面有个扭扣的
这个上面就是这样子
可以给它收上来
当一个短袖
码50 棉50
来这个胸围
胸围的话是100到110
长度67
这个原来49的
给你们19
19扣1
这个牌子能看到吗
这个牌
19块19块
扣1扣1
飞机标也有的
送了一个扣
码50 棉50的这个
来这个有钥的扣
可以当个短袖的
这个是
蓝色的七分袖吧
应该
来这个19块
19块
扣1扣1
绵麻绵麻的这个
扣货全都在这个袋里
我天这个蓝色也出来了
早几天有人要
你看找不到
这一包里面有4件了
我天哪
勾货勾货
蓝色也出来了
蓝色蓝色的
来这个腰围
腰围64
64 72
寻常寻常81
来这个29
扣9
29块
扣9扣9
这个也是和那个粉色的一个牌子
QU11的
QU11的一个蓝色
一个粉色
两条子出来了
嗯
这是那天有人问我找不找
不知道在这里呢
手上手机拍上去好亮
这个颜色
елич
一个白粉色一个蓝色
都出来了
扣111了
开张
谢谢
363 29
漂亮
原来59的多少
我留了两条
那时候都是59留的
你现在我亏大了
我
来263
谢谢
我拿一下
OK
好的
看我的小伙伴
这有个发带送给你
我妈呀
这有个小发带送你一个
口罩没看见
有小发带里面
送你了
谢谢打漂亮
谢谢
好的
来这一款
这个的话是一个小外套
军绿色军绿色的外套
你要发带你又不送
我不知道这里面啥时候放了一个发带
我昨天前天休息的时候还没有
你也有
你也有就送给你们
到时候我再给你找去
这里面没有了
好像就这一个
打这么巧呢
你那天送一个我还早半天
送了个粉红的
粉红的现在药也没有了
来这个
这个是
送了粉红的都不知道是个啥
那不是发带吗
他们说是发带
当时卖10块钱9块9一个的
来这个宣伪102106
长度75
来这个有药的科抹胸
那个应该就是发带
他们说是发带
刚开始卖的时候
都是按发带卖的
来这个有药的科
这个29扣1
29块扣1扣1这一块
底下是松拧的
这一块是底下是一个松拧
松拧
两边是小松拧的
两边是有协差口袋
向往全力发出了
是抹胸
那我还是不知道的
当时卖的时候那时候多
那时候来货
来了好多那种
都是按发带卖的
说都是当发带用
我也不清楚是干啥用
来这个春夏秋都可以穿的一个
马甲
然后是镂空的这种空调房
可以穿穿看很好
气线真正特别软
是一个人棉婚房
胸那么小
来这个胸围
胸围的话是86
86120长度63
来这个
长度是63的
2019块
53 53不是63
我说咋那么长
53的